good morning John this video is going to
be a an attempt at being honest about
myself which is never easy in 2007 I
very clearly remember sitting on my
couch in my apartment with my wife's
laptop which had a light scribe CD
burner where you could burn like a CD on
one side and then turn it over and you
could burn an image on the other side
like a grayscale image and I made
somewhere between like 50 and 100 of
these to take to a library event that
you and I were doing in Michigan and
then I sold every single one of them
last year I got a tremendous desire to
own one of these and so I asked the
internet and Sarah sent me hers and
didn't even ask for any money but did
ask for a favor in the future and she
has not yet called in that favor here it
is it's called several songs from Hank
Green's pants weird piece of trivia for
you that image there of the nerd fighter
skull and crossbones was designed by
viart the math YouTuber also there is an
El Cordova song on this who is this
person she's become popular on on Tik
Tok and Instagram recently but back in
2007 was a YouTuber the fact that people
were willing and excited to buy things
from me that I made was very new and it
led directly to the creation of dftba
records with my friend Alan dftba is now
15 years old and over those 15 years a
lot of good stuff and bad stuff and
amazing stuff and hard stuff has
happened to that company over that time
though it's become quite big I think
over 50 people now work for dftba
fulltime most of what that company has
done and does is help creators create
and sell cool products to their
audiences which we love to do and you
can find lots of products at dftba.com
we also work with the maoy brothers and
with kurs kazad we're the logistics
behind the Dropout TV story we work with
a weird company called item label that I
love so much but in 2016 we started the
first iteration of what has become the
awesome socks Club at that point we were
shipping at around 400 pairs of socks
per month and donating a bunch of money
to charity and we were very proud of
that and it felt very good that number
is is a little different now and around
then I bought a domain name a relatively
expensive one that I sat on for many
years paying for it despite the fact
that we were not using it it was good.
store very cool very Sleek no Doom about
it and I didn't know what it was for but
I thought it would be good to have now
this is the part that I'm not really
looking forward to but I just want to be
honest and I know if you think less of
me afterward that's okay as the awesome
sock Club grew and also as complexly
grew and a bunch of other stuff started
happening in my life I began having a
specific feeling so first I sold VidCon
then I had a book come out that did very
well then I realized that like I didn't
enjoy living a much more expensive
lifestyle than I had previously and I
realized that like I didn't need money
and the jobs were hard like there were a
lot of problems to solve and I didn't
always feel like I was doing a good job
of solving them and also had all those
other things going on in my life and I
was stressed out and I was thinking like
what if I just didn't do these things
anymore but like you can't stop doing
them there's people who work for these
companies there's people who work with
these companies I like all of those
people people who benefit from and enjoy
the things that the companies make that
wasn't a good combination it was like I
felt like that should be enough
motivation and maybe it should have been
like just serving those people but I was
super stressed out and having a hard
time being excited about the work and I
was just doing it because I had to which
is okay like that's part of life but I
wanted other motivations and John you
gave me one when you were like what if
we promised to raise $25 million for a
hospital in Sierra Leon where one in 17
women die in child birth and we don't
know how we're going to raise that money
like we don't have that money but let's
figure out how to do it that's very
motivating and that's exciting to me in
a way that making more money for myself
was not and I kept getting more and more
excited about that domain name but we
decided to sit on the domain name for a
while like what else can we do as a
subscription like what else do people
need regularly so we worked really hard
to try and find some great ethically
sourc absolutely delicious coffee by
chance there is a company in my town
that makes like luxury high quality
private label soaps so we started to do
soaps with sunbed and soap and this is
going to be followed by more
subscriptions like tea that's a lot of
different places for people to have
individual subscriptions to individual
things especially if we could be putting
multiple of those things in one box and
sending them to you rather than having
them be in a bunch of different boxes
and so welcome to the good store as I
sat on that domain name I began to
develop a secret goal and goals are good
for motivation I shared this goal with
LJ when we were in the interview process
to bring her on as CEO of dftba and she
was like yes yeah so when we were first
thinking about this stuff of course
Newman zone is the thing that we were
looking at as a model it's this company
started by Paul Newman who was an actor
who was like I don't need the money but
I want to make salad dressing and we'll
give all the money to charity his quote
was let's give it all away let's give it
all away it's a powerful idea my goal
and I don't know if he'll ever beat it
but it's a goal is to beat them like
companies are always competing against
each other for market share and for
higher profit than the other company
Newman zone is the only as far as I know
big consumer brand that gives all of its
profit away except maybe good store now
Newman Zone over the course of its
existence has given away more than $600
million to charity and good store is
nowhere close to that like we need to
operate at our current levels for
hundreds of years to reach that I don't
know whether we'll ever get there but it
is exciting to me it is inspiring I
think it's exciting for me the way that
making more and more and more money is
inspiring for other people I'm just not
like those people and you'll notice that
Newman Zone doesn't have like a separate
website for all of its different
products so we're going to steal that
from them as well goodstore is now the
landing page for all of the different
things in addition we needed a team
internal at dftba dedicated to making
things with and for a good store it's a
super small team but they're really
focused on trying to find new ethically
sourced highquality products that make
life better and simple right now the
store is chalk full of holiday specials
and bundles there's my cancer socks that
I designed there's bath boxes with new
dreamy descriptions there's coffee
coffee boxes for all the caffeinated
folks in your life all these things make
awesome gifts for people you love or you
can gift them to yourself we won't tell
But be sure if you want to get them by
December 24th to order on or before
December 8th that's the last day we
guarantee shipping for Christmas Eve and
just so you know based on like current
trends these will probably sell out
before December 8th like they might not
but that's what it it's looking like
right now we'll probably order more of
them in the new year but as far as our
current stock they're running low so I
know a fair amount about business now
which isn't really what I had intended
to have happen but one thing that I do
know is like there's ways these things
work and they work the way that they
work one because like that's the way
people do things and like it's easier to
do things the way people have done them
before but also there are like reasons
like there's no way you could do this
idea in the traditional way people start
businesses like you're not going to get
Venture Capital funding if your business
model is giving the profit away so there
are things that are necessary for doing
it this way first you have to do it
slower like it was 2016 when we first
had a sock subscription and now it's
it's almost 20 24 most venture-backed
product startups uh move very fast they
try to Blitz the market they try to
acquire customers super fast we're just
going much slower than that everything
we do has to be self-funded everything
we do has to we to try and do the right
thing all that stuff's tricky but the
second thing and I think this is why
Newman's Zone was possible too is you
have to have some Foundation you have to
have something to build off of I know
for a fact like it's just a fact that
the success of good store wouldn't be
possible without the foundation of this
community already I think it's quite a
bit bigger than this community I want it
to be much bigger than this community
but that Foundation was necessary for it
to have been possible to have a business
that is different like this to recognize
that that this isn't an idea that exists
independently of nerd Feria we're having
what we're calling the founders Club you
can join the founders Club soon it's not
ready yet it'll be a place where you can
contribute new ideas you can get early
access to some products maybe we might
test some stuff on you maybe we might
give some discounts to early stuff so
that you can try them out let us know
what you think about it there will be
various perks and we're building it out
over the next few months if you're
interested in joining the founders Club
you can sign up for the good dot store
newsletter I've put a link to that in
the description it's right at the top we
will be in touch early next year so
again honesty I do not usually know what
I'm doing I often times wish that I was
different from me like I wish there were
things about me that were different I've
tried to change them I have worked
against it when I need to but that juice
only runs so far but the things that
this community can do together are very
different from what a normal business bu
can do like the limitations are
different and the advantages are
different and understanding that those
differences and then using that
understanding to implement something
that is quite different from how it
would be done by someone else that's
like very spicy for my brain and holding
this in my hand the seed from which all
of this grew is really special to me so
thank you Sarah and the thing that I
feel holding it isn't really impostor
syndrome because I don't feel like I'm
trying to pretend to be something that
I'm not but it is absolutely a feeling
of not knowing knowing what I'm doing or
whether I'm doing it right and like
being okay with that I'm so proud of all
of the things that this community and
all of the people who have worked for
VidCon or dftba or complexly or any of
the things that we work on have built
and continue to build I'm really excited
for what I think is a pretty big new
chapter in this I hope I don't know who
knows maybe this is as big as it will
ever get regardless it's already very
big and is doing a lot of good and John
I look forward to doing like whatever is
next with you and I'll see you on
Tuesday